welcome to the first in a series of deep
dives into blink my name is Paul Irish
and I am a developer advocate on Chrome
and here today we have erik seidel eric
is a software engineer on blink that's
correct and but you've been a long time
a developer inside the WebKit community
that's correct I've been on WebKit for I
don't know since 2005 something I've
been that's a a tissue a long long time
hi okay okay and so today we're going to
share kind of kind of the state of the
state of blink yeah we're going to give
an update on blink how things are going
great okay let's get into it so yeah so
a lot of these slides today were taken
from our blink blink on conference which
was a couple months ago we had something
around 200 contributors from the blink
community come to the San Francisco
office it was about half Googlers about
half open source folks and we just
talked to my blink and the slides and
recordings of the main room talks are
all available online yeah I don't like
20 different talks spanning from
performance and layout in the future of
kind of all these directions so things
that are interesting for both blink
developers and web developers so I cared
you to check out the slides in video
yeah definitely so yeah blink has been
around now about eight months I April
for 2013 is when we forked WebKit and
became blink and we are really a pretty
serious open source product about on the
size of the Linux kernel or so about
2,000 commits a month too many
contributors and it's not just Google we
got companies from Samsung to Intel to
Adobe we even had a commit from
Microsoft Research last month we got all
sorts of folks contributing the blank
personally I love this slide this is
shows our size of our source space over
the last couple years and you can see
that big discontinuity around april this
year that was when we blinked blink for
us was a lot of letting go WebKit is
this amazing source space that as you
say has existed for a very long time and
is really everywhere everybody watching
this probably has WebKit in the
device that they're holding in their
hand or their computer that's sitting in
front of them and WebKit is part of
being everywhere has been this square
peg that has been shoved into lots of
round holes and although it's beautiful
on the inside has had this really
difficult time interacting with some
pizzas and for us it was about letting
go of a lot of these pieces of WebKit
that we didn't need so that was blank we
we have spent a lot of the last say
eight months time to take our
integration with WebKit which looked a
lot like this to something maybe a
little bit more like this and now we've
since that time since blink on been
trying to shift our focus more to doing
new things with blank and so that's a
little bit of what we're going to talk
about today great so one of the big
things that's changed in the browser
world in the last five years is that
five years ago web developers had the
question of well do I write for ie do I
write for Firefox where do I develop
this thing these days developers are
making the choice of do i write
objective-c or do i write HTML you know
mobile is king and the question is do I
write a mobile app or do I write a web
app and we're really acutely sensitive
that in the blank world so browser
compatibility is way better we have way
better standards and mobile is king and
that has changed what we think about so
these days in blink now that we're
trying to do less as being just blink
and not part of the larger WebKit
project we're trying to do less and
we're going to try to do it better and
we're trying to take pieces that were in
blink for sort of historical reasons or
we're in the WebKit source repository
for historical reasons and move them out
to other places and simplify things so
that's again simplify and be faster
that's a lot of what we're trying to do
so one of things we talked about it at
blink on again to this this crowded
developers is that this is what the
architecture blank looks like today one
gigantic blah looks pretty scary looks
pretty scared and we'd really like to to
again to simplify in part so we can do
some of these things better or faster
and so this is a more complicated
diagram of trying to break out some of
the pieces of blink and all of this work
is actually already underway if you're
following the blinked at mailing list
you'll see that the
platform bubble is already well on its
way to becoming a reality and then we
even talked about even crazier you know
crazier to us visions of taking the core
rendering engine and even breaking that
down further and maybe taking parts of
that core ndering engine and instead of
having it written in really low-level
c++ that you know it maybe had to be 15
years ago maybe we're writing some of
that in JavaScript and you know moving
that out to you know higher level
abstractions yeah I'm curious one thing
I see on here is the loader and the
loader i believe is kind of this this
thing that there's a lot of mystery
around how it works but it was curious
how does that differ from what we're
seeing here in the fetch what's the
what's the difference between fashion
later uh it's really just an internal
division fetches actually may have the
backwards on this diagram but but one is
the higher level primitives of like
doing a document level load and I think
fetches the lower level primitives of
like actually talking to the the
underlying networking sacks I gotcha so
yeah so going back to our focus one of
the things that we hear time and time
again is that you know we're not fast
enough blank and a lot of that really is
about getting out of the developers way
and so we talked again a lot it blink on
about how do we make the web better how
do we make the book better for for
mobile and specifically that's a lot
about getting out of the developers way
I guess the important thing here is like
and getting out of developers away a
good example is like an animation loop
so every time in an animation loop like
there's a lot of ways to animate a
common example is you take jquery and
you grab an element you say anime can
you say like left and you want to move
it left 200 pixels or something like
yeah and in every tick of the animation
has to happen a lot of things that the
browser has to do the browser has to run
layout has to run paint maybe s closet
layers but these are operations that
have to occur from the browser side
independent of how much JavaScript the
developers running sure and so in
getting out of the developers way we're
saying we
we want to just all the time that's
spent inside kind of the main thread the
developer should have control out of
control of so that the browser is kind
of stepping back just saying here's a
big highway do whatever you want totem
we're going to accelerate it totally and
that is one of the complicated things
especially for being a multi-process
browser is that you know we're
coordinating between all these processes
but but as you say the main thread
belongs to JavaScript belongs to the
developer and we just need to get out of
their way so so in summary we're trying
to do fewer things in blink and we're
trying to do them faster and this was
really the message that we that we were
trying to communicate to the larger
blink community a blink on and are
repeating to you here today so the the
other half of the talk that that Adam
Mars and i gave to open blink on was we
did talked about some of these
architectural changes and we also talked
about what we're doing in the next six
months and so we want to talk a little
bit about that today as well great so in
the very near term we've been working a
lot on this web components future you
know custom elements and all that jazz
and some of that work that's needs to be
going on a blank is try make that's a
fast because doing crazy different
things and what at the web was used to
doing ten years ago and so that's a lot
of work our work is going today we're
also working on the w3c has this web
animation spec and working on getting
that ready to ship this is kind of a new
platform primitive unifying all the
animation models that have existed and
we actually brought up like a jquery
animation loop is I going to go and
there's a new I think this is so I
believe it's Elam animate just a method
right on all elements and it it looks
just like you used to with jquery so
that's there's that and it's kind of
like a shorthand sugar version but
there's this very extensive API for kind
of timing synchronizing all the stuff
yeah it's really powerful but inside
blink that's all about we just got to
rejigger all that architecture and unify
it all down into one code base we're
trying to work better with our chromium
brethren on the other side of the
repository line and things like the
compositor try two more tightly couple
blink
with its embedding layer in chromium
we're working on making fonts look
beautiful everywhere especially on
Windows where we've historically had
some you know kind of ugly font
rendering and we're trying to make that
nicer yeah can you talk a little bit
about kind of the current state of that
effort so when I first heard up these
slides several months ago you know
things were a lot worse than they are
today but thankfully have a really
skilled engineer who's done a great job
and getting our fonts to scale smoothly
on Windows he's been moving our our
windows font rendering to use a the same
complex text rendering path that we have
on on other platforms and there's been a
lot of progress there and there's going
to be a lot more good right now we also
I didn't talk about this earlier but one
of the big changes with blank is that
unlike in WebKit where we would have
dash WebKit foo you know as a CSS
property as a way the sort of experiment
with that CSS property we don't do that
in like we do runtime runtime enabled
features so runtime flags and we don't
have a dash blink prefix and we've been
slowly removing the dash WebKit prefixes
yeah I'm actually just heard yesterday
or so this week Mozilla has adopted a
new policy for introducing new features
and they as well will not be introducing
any new oh really vendor prefixed
property great homes so it's cool that's
a really great use yeah and we've also
been as we talked about in some of the
previous slides trying to module eyes
blink you know make these individual
components though they're smaller so we
can understand them so we can make them
faster and of course we were working on
performance it was very important to you
know remind the whole community that's
it blink on and you know tell you this
is our main focus in blank making things
fast so looking a little further out SVG
has not had layer support which means
you can't do it has been graphics
accelerated all that sort of things and
so we've been working on trying to add
that basic graphics primitive that we
have in the rest of HTML in the SVG
there's some nutty old code called the
widget tree which used to integrate with
the underlying OS platform so like on
Mac web kid you could actually access NS
views for your like I frames and stuff a
lot of that stuff is gone some of this
was to support plugins but we still have
some of that architecture there and
where it will work on a remand some of
that one of the things that we also have
an active effort for is that we're
moving the page level components a blink
up into the browser process so the blink
will only deal with a single frame at a
time and this is called out a process I
frame so that means that for a given
page one blink process one renderer
process might men render the mainframe
and then some other you know
cross-origin iframe will be rendered by
some other process a blink this is
really good for security so this is
mostly driven by security this is mostly
driven by severity are there I guess
there's no real performance benefits
here fully means if that ad is is you
know chewing up the main thread doing
lots of JavaScript it's not going to
slow down your main page so it's nice
for web developers in that regard yeah
great we're also experimenting with you
know some wild and crazy ideas of
unifying the garbage collection so
javascript is a garbage collected
language we've looked at or there's an
active effort called oil pan which you
can check out today it's it's in one of
the branches on blinks repository to use
the JavaScript garbage collector from
sequel spots we're trying to remove a
whole host of features some of these are
already gone but there's a lot more to
go yeah and you'll actually see
on blinked up on the mailing list you'll
see intent to remove yeah for a lot of
these just the most recent one was
display compact maybe something like
that yeah I had no idea display run in
and display compact or both God the
we've talked about removing the old
status bar the toolbar API is from
window back from the Netscape days oh
yeah good so there's active discussion
of those sorts of things on linkedin and
again as we talked about before
rewriting parts of the engine as in
javascript or just making them modular
components we so that's more stuff that
we're working on in the medium term and
of course again performance that remains
our focus and then some more wild and
crazy speculative things that we talked
about again at blink on parallel
parallel execution threading for the
HTML parser worked really well for us
and we've talked about doing some of
that maybe for layout for style for
parsing JavaScript so this is happening
on a separate thread just basically get
get off in the main thread one of the
things that we have to balance with that
is that your phone only has so many
cores and so threading doesn't
necessarily help if you don't have a lot
of course but on your desktop you you
may have lots and lots of course so that
that's balanced and something we're
exploring in the longer term there's
something that like are we able to
measure kind of the i guess the HTML
parser is a good example where that when
to the second thread yep and we able to
mend measure kind of the performance
impact of that especially in the case of
a phone with only two cores yeah we
actually the HTML parser rewrite them
that we did a couple years ago now it
turns out was a win it was I think it
was a slight loss for a single core
machine but like one or so percent but
for two or more cores it was like an
eight percent or more win Wow so it was
pretty serious and we have a lot more
work to do on that a lot of that win
actually was about getting you to load
parts of the page faster so in case a
more while and crazy stuff just like for
a regular expression engine the modern
technique is to use just in
time compiling we could do the same
thing for style matching which is also
like a regular expression engine you
know doing matching we could do you know
maybe a little something like that
that's while I'm crazy but we have some
people thinking about it nice we've
talked about having a fast mode for
blank where we turn off a lot of the
less used features where do you have
some of this in the engine so this is
something like kind of a mode that you
opt in to kind of like strict mode and
BA where you just say okay I want to be
in fast mode and more stricter feature
set correct allowing developers to trade
old crazy compatibility features for
speed yeah we don't know exactly what
that would look like yet again this is
way off into the speculative but it's
it's something we're thinking about like
it so again as we've talked about moving
more and more out of the actual blink
repository some of the stuff you know
blink maybe shouldn't be in the job of
maintaining this code and this is also i
think yes for rewriting again sort of
the same story we're just we're trying
to break things down this was one of our
big messages blink on yeah makes sense
so I think that car about covers it I
definitely encourage folks to watch the
slides you can read all about
contributing to blink at chromium
network / blink and you can join the
discussion for these intent to
implements intend to remove at at
blinked out young obscure Google blinked
of the intent to implement all the
intent threads are really kind of
fascinating to watch and Mozilla
actually in addition to removing vendor
prefixes is also adopting those intent
threads on Mozilla dev platform so it's
gonna it gives a really nice view of
kind of the shape and changes of the web
platform as they evolve by blink Tevez
definitely just a great place to reach
out and get involved yeah thanks for
watching I'm Paul Irish and join us
again next time when we go into blink
you